challenge play the egg opening once at
the start of the game then play egg
again sometime later in the game as well
all hail the duck king
wait what
so multiple eggs that's an interesting
challenge
young children close your eyes don't try
this at home
so the egg opening
is
you have to start with the e pawn
because we have to spell
spell the word egg
light moves first
who's candace
um
sounds like candy
i think all abort and
play a new game
playing oh playing resilient oh i'll
feel bad
yeah well we'll play the egg why not
oh
i feel like it was a proper england
gambit i really prefer to see you play
it again as black smile
well now
but i'm playing the egg
so the eggling gambit
is
i have to spell
egg a e g g
and then e again
so it's a delay england
but it's eggland
and then g again
well now i'm just playing the egg egg
this is the egg egg gambit
egg
egg now i'm just down to pawns
what am i doing with my life
okay i'll play this move
so i guess the point of this opening is
to give white a false sense of
confidence
and then
then make some scrambled eggs
or maybe an omelette
wow look at this move
double attack
going full ham
making a ham omelette
oh white just defends everything
okay let's play serious now
try and work with this position
i have the queen and bishop lined up
have some pressure against the pawn
uh resilient
is just playing normal chess
playing very uh
very solid respectable moves
i'll play this move
this move looks interesting actually egg
land gambit was an absolutely incredible
way to satisfy that challenge
yeah
[Music]
i feel satisfied but i also feel still
hungry for
[Music]
for more eggs
i don't have any e or g pawns left
i think i'll play this
the idea is to
great pressure against e4 also creating
the pin
[Music]
hey it's exalted in the chat
yeah this is the xqc thing the wooden
shield
it's so wooden so it's basically
surrounded by white pieces
so
and resilient just being so resilient
defending
everything but okay now i could take and
take
i'm giving away my wooden shield to get
some
some light action
you eating sand which is
a prime sub
okay
i should really develop more pieces
i i've held off on moving any other pawn
b2
premium reasonable move
i'm scared of this diagonal
i think i'll play f6
you like castle
f6
let's see what the knight has to say
and there was option of queen b4 bishop
d2
[Music]
but i want to castle and play rook e8
and exploit the e-file
bishop e3
yeah that's a very cold-blooded move i'm
counter-attacking the queen
so i'll counter-counter-attack the king
and then there's a counter counter
counter
to my queen
beach cafe opening
oh the beach cafe
how crazy do we want to get
okay
wait a minute
i want to play this move but then i get
i got porked
knight g6 is a
a pin with a long h-file and a fork
that's crazy
i could take the bishop taking the
bishop actually makes sense
last challenge play a totally serious
game like you would for a otb tournament
show us something awesome from your prep
okay
i actually like that challenge
well what do i do first
the beach cafe or like serious opening
prep challenge
i have an e-pawn
now i need to make a g-pawn
this h pawn needs to turn into a g pawn
and i can play the egg one more time
can we get a three egg omelet
it's difficult but
theoretically possible
that's good this
d-pawn is here it's ready to
become an e-pawn
[Music]
oh no
one wants to hurt my
future g-pawn
let's move the king over
okay epon reborn
all i want is one more egg
apologies to those who wanted serious
chess to stream i i will play i'll do
this challenge towards the end
of one
very least one serious game
uh-oh
is that a blunder
i'm getting a little bit carried away
with
i could take but it's not good
[Music]
i don't think i should take that
wait
i wonder if resilient's watching or has
any idea what i'm going through right
now
if i take here there's rook takes rook
i can't even accomplish the egg if i
play that
i think i'll play this move
here we go okay this is what i want oh
no
oh no my egg
i think of this i play e4
if takes here i win the i win them more
material
so hopefully i wouldn't take there
why is eric worry the upper rook because
i'm trying to
i'm trying to fulfill arbitrary moves
um
yeah let's start with this
let's fill this
okay i'm simplifying a little bit
get ready for it
okay e
g
g
triple egg
can i do quadruple egg
to queen the g pawn
oh no
[Music]
wait go away
what is this rick doing here
e
g
d
wait i just lost my my dad invented eggs
okay
wait really
was your dad a chicken
or an egg
okay
let's uh
let's try and finish this now
okay i think you're resilient
oh sorry to to do
this i feel bad playing chess like this
but
yeah you can't spell egg without gg